hello and welcome i'm james murphy
in this video we're going to be talking
about the restrict keyword in c
it's the only keyword in c that has no
analog in c plus plus and it's actually
an important one
c plus was originally started as
essentially an extension for c to
support classes
and as you can see over the years c plus
has gained a number of features that c
just doesn't have
c is a much smaller and simpler language
than c plus plus
there are a few keywords on the left
hand side here for c that don't appear
on the right hand side for c plus plus
like generic but most of the things like
generic have some analog in c plus in
this case generic is kind of c's way of
doing what c plus uses templates for
however restrict is a different case
there is nothing in c plus plus that
does what restrict does in c
restrict is what's called a type
qualifier like const or volatile except
restrict can only be applied to pointer
types so it doesn't make sense to have a
restrict int
restrict is a promise that lets the
compiler know that the programmer
guarantees that no object that i access
through a restrict pointer will be
accessed through any other means besides
the restrict pointer
making this promise allows the compiler
to be able to do more optimizations that
it might not have been able to do before
for correctness reasons
look what happens when i get rid of the
restrict qualifier
you can see that the assembly has six
instructions
but
when i have the restrict in there it's
only five instructions
if we take a look at the assembly output
here on the right we see that the
instructions without the restrict
qualifier do something that's seemingly
redundant
first off it starts by
making a copy of the amount variable and
then adding that into the star x
variable basically
and then it makes another copy of the
amount variable the one that we just
read two lines before
and then it does the subtraction and
then returns
so why did the compiler choose to read
again and make another copy of the
amount variable
when it just did the exact same thing
two lines before
well the reason is the compiler doesn't
know what these x y and amount are
pointing to
it's possible that someone passed in the
same thing for x as they did for amount
and in that case
this line where we're changing the value
that x is pointing to is also changing
the value that amount is pointing to so
when i go to do the subtraction in the
next line the value for amount has
changed
since it's theoretically possible that
the value that amount is pointing to has
changed the compiler has no choice but
to read it again
suppose though that as the programmer we
know that it doesn't make sense to pass
in the same thing for amount in x
then we can tell the compiler i
guarantee you compiler that this
variable is not pointed to or accessed
by anything else and the way that we do
that is with the restrict keyword
as you can see once i add in the
restrict keyword on x the compiler
deletes the redundant read
logically speaking it probably makes
sense to mark all three of these
pointers restrict but in this case it
doesn't allow any extra optimizations
in this example we're implementing a
simple addition of two vectors of length
n so we have source one and source two
which are of length n and we're supposed
to store the answer to the addition in
the destination variable
looking at the assembly output we see
that there are about 46 instructions but
when i add the restrict keyword
then it goes down to only 29
instructions
that was a pretty big difference by
adding the restrict keyword onto the
destination which is essentially saying
that i'm guaranteeing that neither of
the source pointers are overlapping with
the destination
then just by doing that
i've cut the code size quite
significantly
what exactly got cut out in all that
mess
glancing at the assembly we see that
there are a lot of these xmm word kind
of things going on and what these
registers are for are vector
instructions so what this code is trying
to do is do the vector addition using
the vector instructions on the machine
meaning it's trying to add multiple
elements together at once
as you can probably imagine though if
the destination overlaps with either of
the sources it might not be correct to
do multiple of these additions at once
let's compare to the assembly that's
without the restrict keyword
in this case we still see that there are
a bunch of vector operations happening
we have this label l4 and then a bunch
of vector operations and then a jump
back to l4 so that's a vectorized loop
but we also see that
there is an unvectorized loop here so we
have l3 and then a jump back to l3 just
using the regular registers
so basically what's happening here is
there's a whole bunch of extra
instructions that the compiler does to
check to see if it would be okay
to use the vectorized instructions and
then it does the vector thing if that's
allowed
otherwise if the source and destination
are overlapping then it's forced to just
do it you know one at a time
in the normal case when your destination
and source pointers are actually
pointing to different things there's no
overlapping going on you're not going to
see much of a performance improvement
and the reason for this is because it
does just check to see if they're
overlapping and if not it does the
vector operations so if you have a
really long array then the vector
operations are still going to be able to
work on your really long array there was
just that one if branch at the very
beginning that had to check whether or
not it can do those operations
but the code for this is quite a bit
bigger so that could cause an
instruction cache miss and there could
also be a cache miss if the processor
weren't able to predict the you know
branch that goes through all these
things and decides that the vector
operations are the correct ones
so should you be going around slapping
restrict onto all of your pointers
probably not
remember restrict is a promise you're
promising the compiler that you're not
going to be aliasing this pointer
nothing else that the restrict is going
to access is going to be accessed by a
different pointer if that makes sense in
the context of your function then go
ahead throw it in there you might get a
speed up but if it doesn't make sense
then don't use it you can run into some
really really hard to find bugs if you
use restrict inappropriately
consider for example this fibonacci
function it takes in a destination which
is pointing to enough memory for n
elements and then it populates
those elements with the first n
fibonacci numbers
so suppose the implementer says
oh you know what the formula for
fibonacci is just adding
right so fibonacci of n plus 2
is just fibonacci of n plus fibonacci of
n plus 1. so why don't i just use the
vector addition
and
call it with destination plus two
destination and destination plus one
this is now violating the restrict
promise since the destination is just
one or two elements ahead of the source
pointers so reading these pointers here
is going to be reading from the
destination pointer essentially a few
iterations later but we promised that we
wouldn't do that that nothing else was
going to be pointing
maybe i didn't know what restrict meant
and so i just went ahead and did it and
well it seems like it's giving the
correct output all my tests are passing
so let's go ahead and you know push it
to production i'll go ahead and compile
it you know and for my release build and
then all of a sudden
i start getting the wrong answers
remember the purpose of restrict was to
enable more optimizations if i was in a
debug build with a low level of
optimization those optimizations might
not have happened then when i go to
compile for the release build
i get a different answer i get the wrong
answer now and it doesn't matter how
many times i test it if my testing build
is not 03 then i'm going to get the
right answer in all of my tests
this is an extremely tricky bug to find
this is one of those cases where because
the n plus two term depends on the n
term and the n plus one term i need to
do things in order i can't do two of
these operations at the same time like i
would in a vectorized situation
that means that for correctness in this
case i really shouldn't have destination
as being a restrict pointer now i get
rid of that and i go back to the correct
answers even at o3
a good practice to follow when you have
one of these situations where you think
you want to add restrict but there might
be some situation where the pointers may
be overlapping is to just have two
versions of the function one that
explicitly allows overlapping and then
one with the restrict keyword then just
make sure that you use the correct one
in your function
if i just call the correct vector ad
that allows overlapping then there's no
more issues with the restricts pointer
and i can still use the restrict pointer
version for the majority of cases where
my pointers are not overlapping
if you've ever heard of mem copy or mem
move this is exactly the strategy that
these two functions use they essentially
do the same thing you have a source
pointer and a destination pointer and
you're going to copy n bytes from the
source into the destination
the only difference between mem copy and
memo is that with mem copy it has the
restrict pointers and so when you do a
mem copy you're not allowed to pass
overlapping source and destination
regions but for move you are you can see
how this might force the implementations
to be different in mammoof you might
have to copy into a temporary buffer and
then copy the temporary buffer into the
destination
but in memcapi since there's no
overlapping you could potentially copy
directly from the source to the
destination
so what's the deal with c plus plus how
come restrict is allowed in c but it's
not allowed in c plus
there was a proposal around 2014 trying
to pave the way to add restrict into c
plus but there was a lot of pushback
namely because restrict is really hard
to make work with classes
how would restrict work with the this
pointer in member functions and what
would it mean to mark a member variable
restrict
there were just too many questions that
didn't have really good answers and it
would have been a ton of work so it just
never really made it in
however i have deceived you just a
little bit if you're willing to move
away from standard c plus meaning the c
plus that's actually defined in the
actual standards document
then there is a way for you to use
restrict in c plus currently every major
compiler including microsoft's clang and
gcc all support a use of the restrict
keyword which is not part of standard c
plus they support a language extension
that allows you to use it anyway
and it seems like underscore underscore
restrict is the way that it's spelled
so if you change all of your restricts
to double underscore restrict or for
some compilers it's double underscore
restrict double underscore then you can
actually use a version of restrict in
your c plus plus code however the
version of restrict that you get from
your compiler may be different than the
version of restrict that you get from a
different compiler they may work in
different situations some may support
references and others not some may
support certain optimizations and others
not and the actual semantics of what it
means to use restrict you now have to
dig into your compiler manual and figure
out exactly what the compiler is
guaranteeing and what you're promising
to the compiler when you use the
restrict keyword
it's not as simple as in c
but if you're really trying to squeak
that last ounce of performance out of
your compiler it might be worth it to
make code that's not portable to all of
c plus plus and just make code that is
only supported by that one compiler and
that's something that's done a lot in
real world applications if you really
really need speed
but for most cases i'm guessing you're
probably not going to need it
hey everyone thanks for watching i know
that was a really technical one and i'm
not even sure how much my audience knows
c and c plus plus but i think there are
enough of you in there that it was worth
making the video so i hope you
appreciated this little you know
technical bit of c
as always thank you to my patrons and to
my donors for supporting me and allowing
me to make more of these videos i really
appreciate your support
lastly if you enjoyed the video don't
forget to like comment and if you
especially liked the video please
consider subscribing or becoming one of
my patrons thanks and see you next time